- Is it true that you run your
songs by your Uber drivers?
- Wow. How do you know that?
- We have really good intel.
- Yeah.
- Here's the thing, I
actually think that's awesome.
- Thank you. Yeah, I love, before corona,
I haven't taken a Uber in
so long, but before corona,
I would like, at my hair
salon, at everywhere.
I'd be like, "Stranger, come here.
What do you think about this?"
And I study people's body language.
Like if I lose them in the
first like, verse and chorus,
I'm like, "Got to fix it."
Or Uber drivers were like,
"This is great. Who is she?"
And I'd be like, "She's a superstar."
- Oh, so you don't, they
don't know who you are.
- No, they've no idea.
- Oh, that's amazing. That's--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm purely testing them on
like, do you like this or not?
- What's a piece of Uber driver feedback
that you can recall?
- I mean, one guy was just
like, "This is so good.
Will you send it to me?" And I
was like, "No. This is like-"
And then I had to explain why,
and then he was like, "No way!"
- And then he was probably
like, "Glad I liked it."
- (laughs) Yeah, right?
And yeah, I've never had
anyone be like, "Mmm."
Which is, thank God, but yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.